LeBron or Jordan
Michael Jordan I think you're wrong but
that's not I think I'm wrong yeah I love
Jordan he's up there how old are you I'm
hey Jordan's my favorite you didn't get
to see Michael Jordan of course I as a
child I have his posters all over my
wall but I still just think LeBron's
better he's been doing it at a high
level way longer than Jordan did
think about it
the year that Jordan came back and
played with the Wizards by the way he
still was putting up buckets almost took
him to the playoffs
I don't know I just think I've used like
it
I don't know about some people that
watch basketball the last 20 30 years
and really got to see Michael Jordan
I just think that the reasons why
Michael Jordan is great like LeBron just
can't live up yeah but it's cool to be
suck it though but you could say the
same thing about Jordan Jordan wasn't as
great of a passer as LeBron Jordan oh he
couldn't do some things better but just
Michael Jordan to I mean LeBron's in
what year 20. yes he's an amazing player
I agree with you I agree with you
I agree with you did you play just
something about Michael Jordan is the it
fact did you play it you know and you
know what it's no of course I mean yeah
it's the six rings it's the killer it's
it's the Killer Instinct the man you
just can't really compare players
strictly basketball all time
LeBron or Kobe
Kobe Bryant for the same reasons why I'm
picking Michael Jordan you're putting
Kobe over LeBron yeah I mean he's your
for one game I'm talking about for one
game I mean you got one game two
possessions we're talking about the goat
list here yeah
Kobe Bryant you put Kobe over LeBron
Kobe Bryant and the reason why I'm I'm
picking Michael Jordan I mean Kobe
Bryant because
Michael Jordan
he's the
set the ball yeah
and
Kobe Bryant was the only one that was
chasing Michael Jordan's greatness
and it was obvious
yeah I don't know man from his walk from
the fade away
teaching his will you um [ __ ]
had 81 points man